[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de la semaine au
Parlement et nous accueillons cette
semaine Mathilde Panau présidente du
groupe la France insoumise à l'Assemblée
nationale bonjour bonjour Merci d'être
notre invité merci à vous et à la une
cette semaine le projet de loi
immigration examiné par la commission
des lois de l'Assemblée nationale les
députés ont rétabli l'aide médicale des
qui avait été restreinte par le Sénat et
ils ont également modifié l'article sur
la régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers en tension
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté jeudi
deux propositions de loi portées par la
France insoumise l'une pour créer une
commission d'enquête sur la gestion des
risques naturels en oututreemère l'autre
pour ouvrir des accueils physiques dans
les services publics et puis la mort du
jeune Thomas crpol dans la Drome
continue de faire réagir les
parlementaires de nombreux députés et
sénateurs ont dénoncé l'expédition
punitive organisée en réaction à ce ce
drame par des militants d'ultra drroite
dans un quartier de roman sur iser le
weekend
dernier les députés ont donc poursuivi
l'examen du projet de loi majeur de
cette fin d'année le projet de loi
immigration en commission des lois ils
ont notamment réécrit l'article visant à
améliorer l'intégration en ouvrant la
voie à des régularisations de
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension l'Assemblée nationale
a par ailleurs réécrit certaines autres
disposition qui avaiit été voté au Sénat
résumé de Stéphanie des piierre c'est le
du débat la régularisation des S papiers
qui travaillent dans les métiers en
tension cet article de la loi avait été
profondément modifié par le Sénat les
députés ont voté une version de
compromis proposée par le rapporteur
Renaissance cette régularisation ne sera
ni un droit automatique ni un pouvoir
discrétionnaire du préfet un dispositif
de régularisation resserré qui
correspond à des besoins économiques qui
permettent aussi de tirer de
l'illégalité et parfois de conditions
inacceptables de maltraitance certain
nombre de ressortissant en situation
irrégulière le préfet pourra refuser de
donner une carte de séjour si l'étranger
menace l'ordre public ou ne respecte pas
les valeurs de la République un
compromis qui ne satisfait ni la droite
ni l'extrême droite le droit de vetto
sera très encadré très difficile
régulariser les métiers en tension c'est
amorcer une pompe inépuisable c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous sommes
résolument opposé aux dispositions de
l'article 4 bis c'est un appel d'air un
appel d'air et nous le maintenons parce
qu'en plus là où c'est grave là où c'est
grave c'est que vous êtes en train de
prévoir la régularisation de gens qui
n'ont pas respecté les lois de la
République pour la gauche c'est tout
sauf un compromis l'appel d'air n'existe
pas il est un myth complet et ça suffit
que vous vous saisissiez et vous
glissiez vers cette idée il est au fond
le refus de regarder la réité en face de
régulariser des travailleurs qui par
ailleurs payent des impôts payent des
cotisations sociales mais ne peuvent pas
payer leur loyer parce qu'ils ne sont
pas capables de produire un titre de
séjour autre sujet inflammable et
chiffon rouge pour la droite l'aide
médicale d'État le Sénat l'avait
supprimé au grand regret du camp
présidentiel les députés l'ont donc
rétabli à l'inverse dès le premier jour
de débat ils ont supprimé les quotas
d'immigration économique que les
sénateurs avaient instaurés voilà mathde
panneau suppression des quotas
d'immigration rétablissement de l'Ame
finalement l'Assemblée nationale a
refait un peu un texte proche de ce qui
avait été proposé initialement est-ce
que vous saluez la volonté de la
majorité de vouloir trouver un texte le
plus équilibré possible alors pas du
tout d'ailleurs nous on conteste même le
fait qu'il y ait un anè texte
immigration puisque c'est le 22e la 22e
loi sur l'immigration depuis
1990 et contrairement à beaucoup
d'autres lois c'est lois n'ont jamais
été évalué sur le bilan de de ce qui
avait été décidé lors de ces lois
pourquoi parce que lorsqu'on parle
d'immigration la question n'est pas
tellement de savoir ce que ça produit
mais de montrer notamment à l'extrême
droite et à la droite on le voit bien
ici comment est-ce que le débat est tiré
par par ces idées qui sont propagées
malheureusement très fortement dans le
champ politique de montrer qu'on fait
quelque chose pour dire qu'on a fait
quelque chose il y a pas de sincérité du
débat pour vous en fait c'est même pas
un problème de sincérité du débat c'est
que est en train de se propager par
cette loi immigration des paroles qui
sont des paroles xénophobes qui sont des
paroles racistes je ne sais pas si vous
avez entendu par exemple le sénateur
reconquête au Sénat qui expliquait
Stéphane Rav qui expliquait que par
exemple on ne pouvait pas naître comme
un veau dans une écurie et devenir un
cheval je vous laisse apprécier la
qualité de cette intervention donc vous
avez bon des des paroles racistes qui
s'expriment comme ça et surtout vous
avez une absence totale de vision
globale de ce qui est en train de se
passer dans le monde nous ne sommes pas
contrairement à ce qui est dit en France
sous un flux migratoire ou une
submersion migratoire
je rappelle que la plupart des
migrations dans le monde sont des
migrations Sud sudud avec des pays du
Sud bien plus pauvres que les nôtres qui
accueillent beaucoup plus de gens que
nous ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que l'extrême
droite la droite et même parfois les
macronistes qui sont les premiers à
pointer du droit les exilés de ce pays
et bien sont ceux aussi et ce sont des
hypocrites pour cela qui adorent les
traités de libre échange qui détruisent
les agricultures vivrières qui acceptte
que l'État fabrique des sanspiers et
c'est le problème avec la régularisation
on va reparler mais notamment parce que
comme vous avez des corps préfectoraux
qui ne peuvent pas suivre à la fin vous
vous retrouvez avec des gens qui étaient
en situation régulière qui deviennent en
situation irrégulière alors selon vous
il n'y a pas de chaos migratoire mais
quand même quand certains étrangers dans
notre pays qui sont condamnés pour des
crimes ou des délits ne peuvent pas être
expulsés car ils bénéficient de
protection est-ce que selon vous c'est
c'est un problème mais écoutez vous avez
plusieurs choses d'abord il y a déjà des
dispositions pour pouvoir expulser des
gens lorsque la loi n'est pas respectée
ça existe existe déjà il n'y a pas
besoin d'une Nème loi pour ça ça c'est
la première chose et j'aimerais que on
ne parle pas juste des exilés je le dis
pas pour vous évidemment mais pour le
débat public général sur seulement sur
des gens qui seraient des délinquants
qui viendraient en quelque sorte parce
que je le dis les personnes notamment
son papier sont celles qui vont vous
emmener vos colis qui sont celles qui
lavent les bureaux et cetera je le dis
là c'est sur les criminel et déin que
certains ne peuvent pas être expulsé oui
mais en fa pouro pourquoi ils sont ils
sont pas expulsables généralement vous
avez ce qu'on appelle le phénomène des
Ninis ni ni expulsable ni régularisable
je ne parle même pas des délinquants là
je parle en général des personnes qui
sont sans papier donc ils ne sont pas
expulsable parce que euh soit les pays
dont ils sont originaires sont des pays
considérés comme non sûrs et je pense
que tout le monde ici est d'accord pour
dire queon va pas renvoyer quelqu'un en
zone de guerre euh ou il ne rentre pas
dans les critères de régularisation et
ça c'est l'autre problème et donc vous
vous retrouver avec des situations où
des gens vont passer jusqu'à 90 jours
dans des centres de rétention
administrative souvent en en n' ayant
absolument rien fait si ce n'est de ne
pas avoir les papiers en règle et donc
vous vous retrouvez dans une situation
qui est une impasse donc ce qui est
promu notamment par l'extrême droite
n'existe pas vous savez combien ça coûte
une exusion faut pas lever certaines
protections certains critères qui
empêchent et bien bah le fait que un
étranger soit arrivé sur notre sol avant
un certain âge avant 13 ans par exemple
bah non moi je pense que je pense que
non lorsque vous avez quelqu'un même
quand c'est un criminel mais bien sûr
lorsque vous avez un criminel qu'est-ce
que vous faites vous faites comme des
criminels qui sont français c'est-à-dire
que vous faites bon de la prison vous
faites bon vous faites ce ce qui doit
être fait dans dans dans la question des
peines mais de tout de même est-ce que
ma panneau un étranger respect de l'État
de droit quoi l'État de droit est-ce
qu'un étranger dans ce cas puisqu'on
parle d'État de droit doit remplir
certains devoirs pour avoir le droit de
vivre sur notre sol notamment parler un
minimum notre langue et respecter les
valeurs de la République de manière
large oui c'est ce qui se passe déjà
actuellement droit et devoir mais ce qui
c'est ce qui est ajouté par le texte
avec un examen de français par exemple
sa non moi je suis pas du tout d'accord
avec avec l'examen de français je suis
en radical désaccord avec ça je vais
vous dire quelle est la réalité de
beaucoup de de familles qui se trouvent
sur notre territoire en situation
irrégulière moi ça fait 2 ans que je
lutte au côté des travailleurs de
Chronopost donc qui sont et donc de de
richichbourg donc ils sont par
sous-traitance des travailleurs employés
par la poste ce que le directeur de la
poste assume puisqu'il explique que du
fait de la concurrence et ben en quelque
sorte il faut faire en sorte que les
conditions de travail et les salaires
soient tirées vers le bas pour pouvoir
faire en sorte de continuer ce ce qu'ils
font l'État est actionnaire majoritaire
avec la casé dépôt de la poste donc
l'état sa ce qui est en train de se
passer puisqu'il y avait déjà eu 73
régularisations en 2019 connaît la
situation et pourtant accepte que des
des des entreprises par s-traitance
comme La Poste emploi des travailleurs
sans papier ceci s'appelle de
l'exploitation et moi ce que j'ai envie
de dire à celles et ceux qui nous
regardent plutôt que de voir les exiler
comme un problème c'est de dire que tout
ce qui est fait pour les droits des
personnes étrangères de ce pays est
quelque chose qui aide l'ensemble du
pays lorsque par exemple vous faites ce
que nous nous demandons la
régularisation de tous les travailleurs
sans papier alors cela cela remonte les
conditions de travail et les salaires de
tout le monde de même que sur l'aide
médicale d'État l'aide médicale d'État
est une politique de santé publique
alors ça a été rétabli ça a été rétabli
bah heureusement heureusement pour une
fois ils sont obligés de la défendre
enfin l'aide médicale d'État pour
répondre à des mensonges c'est 0,4 % des
dépenses de santé et sur les cas de
fraudes qui avaient été examinés c'est
0,06 % de 0,4 % et alors pourquoi les
insoumis ne défendent pas l'article du
projet de loi qui prévoit en tout cas
qui prévoyait initialement et bien une
régularisation automatique des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tenstion alors que à gauche
des communistes des socialistes et
l'elle gauche de la majorité à défendre
ce cet article initial parce que nous
nous défendons la régularisation de tous
les travailleurs sans papier je vais
vous expliquer il y a deux choses qui
nous posent problème dans la dans la
version euh qui est actuellement
discutée la première des choses c'est
que que les titres de séjour sont
seulement donnés pour 1 an si vous
parlez à qui que ce soit en préfecture
quel que soit le niveau de
responsabilité des préfets jusque aux
équipes vous comprenez que vu le manque
de moyens qu'on les préfectures
aujourd'hui eux-mêmes demandent à ce que
on passe plutôt à des titres de séjour
de 5 ans de 10 ans qui permettent
justement que l'État ne fabrique pas des
S papiers du fait de l'absence de
réponse qui puisse être faite ça c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose
c'est que vous allez avoir donc une
liste de métiers intention qui du jour
au lendemain pourra être changé et donc
du jour au lendemain remettre des gens
dans une irrégularité et donc vous avez
avec cet article là une idée d'un d'un
travailleur un peu jetable qui serait
qui serait utilisé que nous réfutons et
donc je le redis nous nous nous battons
pour la régularisation de tous les
travailleurs sans papier alors ma
panneau l'ambience est assez houleuse en
commission des lois durant l'examen du
texte le député insoumis Hugo
bernanissis a provoqué une altercation
avec un autre député il lui a attrapper
le bras Hugo Bernal demander une
suspension de séance pour pouvoir
assister dans
l'hémicycle discussion de vos textes LFI
est-ce que pour vous votre député a
dérapé monsieur bernalis alors Hugo
bernalicis s'est levé à part lesff N a
été violent avec personne ça c'est la
première des choses deuxième chose lors
de notre niche parlementaire il POS
attraper le bras c'est pas violent
attraper le bras d'un collègue c'est pas
écoutez moi j'étais pas là parce que
j'étais en niche parlementaire mais pour
moi Hugo bernalici s'est levé à parler
fort et à notamment exiger parce que ça
c'est une question de fond qui est posé
la question de fond c'est pourquoi
est-ce que lors des niches
parlementaires je rappelle que c'est le
seul jour dans l'année dont on peut
choisir l'ordre du jour il y a des
commissions qui se tiennent en même
temps ça c'est la première question et
puis surtout on avait commencé un texte
qui dépend la commission des lois et
donc des commissaires aux loi et il y
avait un engagement que ça soit arrêté
pour que tous les commissaires en loi
puissent être en HM une sanction Hugo
bernalessis on
verra vous savez il y a le brune pivé et
la présidente de l'Assemblée qui a donné
le plus de sanctions de toute l'histoire
de la 5e République donc alors on va
parler des Tex justement qui étaiit
alors du jour puisqueeffectivement vous
avez disposé de de l'ordre du jour de 9h
à minuit et de de propositions de lois
que vous avez défendu et ont été adopté
l'une pour créer une commission
d'enquête sur les risques naturels en
outre M et l'autre pour réinstaurer un
accueil physique dans les services
publics adoptés par 122 voix contre 29
text portés par Daniel auono
écout les outils numériqu sont porteurs
de progrès dans de nombreux domaines par
contre lorsquell participe de politique
de restruction budgétaire et
s'accompagne du recul des implantations
territoriales la numérisation des
services publics conduit à des ruptures
d'accès au droits pour une part non
négligeable de la population notamment
pour les personnes les plus précaires
qui sont confrontées aux démarches les
plus complexe voilà votre texte a été
adopté contre l'avis du gouvernement qui
rappelle que de nombreuses maisons
France servic ont été créées depuis 2019
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez alors la
première chose c'est je crois que c'est
une victoire très importante que la
victoire sur ce texte y compris parce
que les services publics sont le
patrimoine de celles et ceux qui n'ont
rien dans dans ce pays et que la
dématérialisation accompagné non pas
juste toute seule mais accompagné de la
disparition des accueils physiques et
donc de la possibilité de parler à un
être humain mais gravement en danger
l'égalité des citoyens devant la
République on parle de 20 % de personnes
dans ce pays qui ont du mal à accéder au
servicees public et je le rappelle il y
a 8 millions de personnes qui sont en
situation d'ilectronisme dans dans ce
pays donc c'est un texte qui est
extrêmement large il se trouve que si
cela a été adopté et d'ailleurs les
macronistes n'ont pas osé voter contre
si ce texte a été adopté c'est parce que
chacun sait que cela répond à une
réalité du pays et que ça soit dans des
zones rurales dans des quartiers
populaires un peu partout vous avez un
effondrement du service public tel et
une réduction du nombre d'agents des
services publics qui fait que je crois
ils n'ont pas réussi à empêcher que
cette proposition de loi pass passe j'en
suis très heureux j'espère qu'elle
passera au Sénat et qu'elle pourra
s'appliquer réellement pour obliger à
avoir une réouverture des guichet
physique et justement est-ce que vous
avez des garanties de vos collègues
sénateurs de gauche qui pourraient
reprendre votre texte et qu'est-ce que
vous dites à la majorité de droite du
Sénat pour qu'elle l'adopte alors je
pense que les républicains de par les
territoires où ils sont élus sont aussi
sensibles à cette question parce que
enfin quand on parle de de cette
question de problème d'accès au service
public on va parler
de la question de l'accès au minimum
vieillesse on va parler d'allocation
familiale de choses très concrètes
d'accès à des droits et d'ailleurs de
papi pour les personnes aussi en
situation irrégulière qui sont qui sont
confronté très durement donc nous nous
allons prendre contact avec les groupes
du Sénat nous l'avons pas encore fait
puisque c'était une victoire que nous
avons vraiment
arraché inattendu pour vous finalement
on va dire que j'avais bon espoir de
commencer la journée par par la vie
victoire sur la commission d'enquête sur
les risques majeurs en outremère qui est
là aussi un thème très large mais je
n'étais pas sûr qu'on arrive ensuite en
a aranché d'autres un mot justement sur
cette commission d'enquête que vous
souhaitiez on vous a entendu dans
l'hémicycle vous vous avez félicité que
l'Assemblée nationale adopte le principe
de cette commission d'enquête sur la
gestion des risques naturels en outreem
en quoi ces risques sont-ils aujourd'hui
mal gérés par l'État on parle de tornade
de
cyclonees en quoi l'état a-t-il failli
alors l'État a failli mais en fait c'est
un débat de société beaucoup plus large
qu'on devrait mener je crois qu'aucun
État au monde aujourd'hui n'est à la
hauteur du plus grand défi de de notre
siècle qui est le dérèglement climatique
et la crise écologique je le dis parce
que comme génération humaine je ne parle
pas la dâge mais comme génération
humaine personne avant nous n'a eu à
affronter un aussi gros problème et une
aussi gros rupture avec nos modèles de
production et et de consommation et donc
ce que ce à quoi sont conf confronter
nos compatriotes ultramarins c'est
d'être en première ligne du dérèglement
climatique parce que ce sont eux qui ont
à la fois vous avez parlé de cyclone
mais aussi un risque sismique un risque
volcanique des sécheresses les risques
sont plus forts en Outremer bien sûr
bien sûr enfin et puis en plus vous avez
beaucoup des territoires ultramarins qui
sont des territoire insulaire pas tous
pas la Guyane ça serait bien de le
rappeler à Emmanuel Macron mais le le
fait d'être insulaire la montée des eau
qui a atteint déjà certaines communes je
pense notamment en Martinique est un
problème auquel ils vont être confrontés
en premier et moi là où je suis très trs
heureuse de cette commission d'enquête
c'est à la fois pour réfléchir quel doit
être le rôle de l'État pour faire face
et protéger nos compatriotes ultramarins
qui sont en première ligne mais c'est
aussi des conclusions et des
recommandations de cette commission
d'enquête qui doivent aider le pays tout
entier parce que ce à quoi ils sont
aujourd'hui confrontés nous y sommes
déjà confrontés mais nous y serons
encore plus confrontés à l'avenir en
hexagone et donc c'est en quelque sorte
faire œuvre d'intérêt général et faire
en sorte qu'on apprenne de la France des
océans mathil pan on va parler du drame
de crpool et de ses suites puisque la
mort du jeune Thomas continue de faire
réagir les parlementaires notamment
après l'expédition punitive organisée en
réaction à ce drame par l'ultra droite
c'était le weekend dernier dans le
quartier de la monnaie à Roman suriser
retour sur les vives réactions au Sénat
et également à l'Assemblée avec les
annonces du ministre de l'Intérieur lors
des questions au
Gouvernement mardi devant les députés
géralde Darmanin affiche sa fermeté va
dissoudre les groupuscules d'extrême
droite auteur de violence après la mort
de Thomas à crpol des moyens nombreux
sont mis pour suivre les 1500 personnes
radicalisées de l'ultra drroite pour
pouvoir les interpeller pour engager les
procédures de dissolution comme je l'ai
fait avec Génération identitaire des
sanctions bien accueillies au Sénat
mercredi mais qui laissent un goût à mer
sur les bancs de la droite d'abord pour
Bruno reetillot la réponse du
gouvernement n'est pas suffisante il ne
faut pas que l'exécutif se réfugie
derrière justement ces groupes d'extrême
droite pour échapper à la vraie
signification de crpool quand vous
écoutez les gens sur place ce qu'ils
veulent eux c'est que la France
silencieuse celle qui ne crée pas de
problème celle qui élève ses enfants
sans haine des Français puisse être
reconnu et que justice soit faite pour
la gauche non plus la dissolution des
groupuscules d'extrême droite ne suffit
pas y brossa demande des sanctions
d'inégibilité contre ceux qui
instrumentalisent ces groupes et font de
la
derrière ces mobilisations il y a en
réalité des donneurs d'ordre et des
responsables politiques qui créent ce
climat de guerre civile je vise par
exemple Marion maréchal je vise Éric
Zemour je vise Marine Le Pen le sang de
Thomas était encore chaud que ces
gens-là passaient leur temps à créer ce
climat de guerre civile et à faire du
racolage électoral la dissolution des
groupuscules sera prononcé mercredi 6
décembre lors du prochain conseil des
ministres math pan est-ce que le
gouvernement assez ferme avec ses
groupuscules d'ultra droite je je je
crois que bon nous on avait alerté dès
2019 en demandant une commission
d'enquête donc dans sur notre droit de
tirage sur la question de la lutte
contre les gropuscules d'extrême droite
je crois non seulement que le
gouvernement n'a pas pris la conscience
de ce qui est en train de se qui c'est
en train de se passer et notamment des
seuils qui sont franchis dans notre pays
et du danger que représente l'extrême
droite dans ce pays avec des
groupuscules qui se sentent en forte
impunité notamment parce que par exemple
quelqu'un comme monsieur sooti a du mal
à condamner l'expédition punitive
raciste qui a eu lieu à roman suzer mais
aussi parce que des responsable
politique je pense notamment à Monsieur
Zemour qui ne cesse d'expliquer que
l'islam n'est pas compatible avec la
République française bon autorise ce
type de parole je rappelle que à roman
suriser il criait Islam hors d'Europe
donc il y a une forme d'impunité qui est
en train de se créer autour des ces
crpuscules et il faut prendre la
conscience de ce qui est en train de se
passer donc le fait que la justice
puisse prononcer des dissolutions
administratives est une bonne chose mais
par exemple je n'ai pas eu la réponse à
une question que nous nous avons posée
comment se fait-il que ces nervis
d'extrême droite qui étaient à Roman
suriser ce soit retrouvver en possession
non seulement des noms et prénoms des
suspects de la mort de Thomas de leur
adresse de leur numéro de téléphone et
de membres de leur
familledz quoi des fuites dans la police
il y a il y a forcément eu des fuites
quelque part pour que des groupuscules
d'extrême droite en soit
dans la police ou peut-être de de plus
haut je je ne sais pas je ne dis pas ça
pour faire polémique je dis ça parce que
ça doit nous interroger et que c'est
grave si des groupuscules d'extrême
droit peuvent avoir accès à ce type
d'information et je vais vous dire nous
avons eu de la chance sur roman suriser
parce que la population a fait preuve
d'un sang-froid incroyable mais cela
peut tourner au drame et lorsque par
exemple nous avons à l'université de de
de
Bordeaux Louis Boyard et Carlos Martin
Milongo qui se retrouve alors qu'ils
font un meeting avec des jeunes à avoir
30 personnes d'extrême droite cagoulé et
avec des barres de fer devant le meeting
que qu'il tenait je le dis nous passons
des seuils qui sont très inquiétants et
nous devons en prendre la mesure et nous
à chaque instant nous nous battrons
contre l'extrême droite mais aussi nous
serons un rempart contre la haine qu'ils
essayent de propager dans le pays contre
la haine alors quelques jours avant ces
événement thomas était poignardé à mort
alors qu'il assistait un un bal commun
est-ce que ce drame de crépom est le
signe de deux Frances qui s'oppos la
France des quartiers contre la France
des villages comme le dit notamment la
droite et l'extrême droite non il ne
faut surtout pas rentrer dedans déjà je
je veux saluer la dignité incroyable
d'une famille touchée par un drame aussi
profond que la mort de leur fils qui ont
demandé instamment lors de la Marche
blanche qu'il n'y ait pas
d'instrumentalisation de la mort de leur
fils et qu'il puisse faire leur deuil
correctement si vous commencez à dire
que c'est une opposition entre la France
euh des des villages et euh la France
des quartiers populaires tout comme
essayent de le faire certains d'extrême
droite aussi d'opposer par exemple euh
nos nos compatriotes de confession
musulmanes avec nos compatriotes de
confession catholiques avec nos
compatriotes de confession juives ou
avec nos compatriotes qui pour la grande
majorité du peuple français n'a pas de
religion alors vous rentrez dans une
forme de guerre civile que veut euh
instaurer réinstaurer l'extrême droite
aidé par la droite dans ce pays qui est
très dangereuse et je le dis à tout
moment comme responsable politique nous
devons être les gardiens de l'unité de
la nation h et donc pour vous il y a
c'est pas une réalité parce que le
ministre de l'Intérieur a parlé et bien
avec ce qui s'est passé il a dit on a
évité une petite guerre civile donc
c'est pas une réalité c'est cette
opposition entre certains certains
territoires je je quand je vous dis que
c'est grave ce qui s'est passé sur roman
sur iser tout comme évidemment le drame
de de la mort d'un jeune homme aussi
jeune que cela est terrifiant pour pour
le pays euh quand je dis euh que nous
avons échapper au pire sur roman sur
iser c'est parce que justement la
question est de savoir risque oui enfin
mais évidemment mais vous avez vu les
les les paroles qui sont tenues dans
dans notre République c'est très grave
donc la la question c'est comment nous
faisons peuple ensemble moi j'aimerais
qu'on discute dans le pays de savoir
comment est-ce qu'on fait que tout le
monde puisse avoir une vie digne et que
dans la 7e puissance économique au monde
il n'y ait pas autant de pauvres dans ce
pays comment on fait face au dérèglement
climatiques plus grand défi de notre
siècle voilà ce qui devrait lier les
gens entre eux et repenser que ce qui
nous lie entre nous c'est notre dev
liberté égalité fraternité comment
comment vous expliquer Mathilde Panau
l'ultravolence de de ces jeunes souvent
très jeunes qui arrivent en bande armée
euh comment vous expliquez ça venu de
ces quartiers malheureusement ce n'est
pas nouveau et pas non pas venu de ces
quartiers enfin en général ce n'est pas
nouveau euh vous si vous lisez par
exemple certains de vos confrères qui
qui racontent les 30000 Apaches qui à un
moment s'est vissé à Paris avec des
phénomènes d'ext d'ext d'extrême
violence c'était en
1900 donc moi je pense traîner comment
arrêter ce genre de de dérive vers
l'ultraviolence de gens très jeunes bon
la la première chose c'est que il faut
un que justice soit faite lorsqu'il y a
des drames ça c'est la première chose
réclameer de la fermeté moi je réclame
le respect de l'État de droit et la
justice voilà je ne réclame pas de la
fermeté particulière je réclame le
respect de l'État de droit la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il ne vous a pas échappé
que notre société est en quelque sorte
malade de savoir quel avenir on lui
réserve et moi ce que je reproche au
gouvernement actuel à Marine Le Pen qui
en quelque sorte l'assurance vie du
système c'est de bloquer l'avenir de
bloquer la perspective de pouvoir se
projeter dans des choses et donc le fait
par exemple que l'éducation n'est pas
assez de moyens dans ce pays a des
impacts concrets qu'on voit
malheureusement rapidement pour conclure
le ministre la justice Éric Dupont
moréti a été relaxé par la Cour de
Justice de la République il était accusé
de prise illégale d'intérêt les insoumis
dénonce un arrangement entre les
parlementaires de la majorité et de la
droite qui composaient ces juges de la
CJR vous avez des preuves de cet
arrangement ben je vais vous donner ce
que disait l'ancien président de la Cour
de Justice de la République Monsieur
Parlos devant une commission d'enquête
dont il avait prêté serement il disait
je dirais que la Cour de Justice de la
République donne l'impression que les
affaires concernant les ministres s'y
résolvent par de petits arrangements
entre amis la décision qui a été prise
de dire que les faits matériels étaient
établis pour dire qu'il y avait un
conflit d'intérêt mais de le relaxer et
un bras d'honneur qui a été fait à la
justice toute entière merci Mathilde pan
d'avoir été l'invité de Parlement Hebdo
c'est la fin de cette émission on te
retrouve très bientôt ciao
[Musique]
ciao